you know this happy little boy look like
a sad little boy oh my god
[Music]
some of you clicking on this video might
be wondering what the hell is an eboy
and the truth is i couldn't answer that
question for you because i have no clue
either
which is why for the next few days of
this work week i will be living
out the life and style of an e-boy
no idea what that means what that
entails that's why we have chase hudson
aka little huddy
coming on by do you know the other day
on hollywood boulevard a man dumped a
bucket of its own diarrhea over a woman
oh i didn't know that actually that's
true story true story
true story an eboy is an internet boy
that wears black has their nails painted
they wear
lots of chains act dark and sad and
edgy not only do i want to kind of fit
the style but i kind of want to live the
life of what people assume an e-boy does
i would love for us to go to the shops
right now for you to help me pick out
some
some clothes to her i'd love to you know
i'll bedazzle you out i'll show you
when i'm out of the shops i'm gonna be
looking for things like
nice plain long sleeves this is me
running on your shirts
perfect and then i'm going to put a like
a vintage shirt over him
i'm going to be looking for a plain
black beanie you look great
how should i be doing my hair this week
how do you notify it i'll be looking for
a nice chain piece like a lot of people
have logs it does it sort of symbolize
how
love is kind of a lock between you and
someone else uh
no those are always cool we're getting
our stuff done
this is getting what's wrong with this
chase you know whose world this
this is our world this is our world
me and my buddy chase just did some
great shopping you guys saw
some tiny stuff too i did i got some
cool stuff i saw him go up to a counter
and i saw him pay for something that was
two hundred dollars for two shirts
wow i was on more of a bit of a budget
but we got some great stuff here we got
some great stuff
we got a harley davidson denim jacket
yeah let's see if they'll be like that
guy rides motorbikes
yeah do you think they'll think of that
no whose world is this whose world is
this your hours
so shout out with me one two three
no this is no it's not my world this is
our world it's our world so we went
shopping on melrose we took over the
street today it's our world
one two three
okay i don't know we're doing that
what a week
the first real day of wearing the look
was tuesday and
it's safe to say that i got a whole host
of different responses around the office
oh my god arya this is not arya
there's so much metal
this is very off-brand for you so i love
it this is kind of cool
it's really hard yeah you look great
i like it you know like a k-pop star
i'm not gonna let you look really cute
like it's so clear that i'm so into this
i want to follow you while you go see
merle oh my god
i'm actually kind of into it i feel like
i want
to like secretly make out with you at
the mall
oh like don't tell my mom i'm a little
flustered
she's sexually flustered the middle part
in the chains were the things i was
definitely most
wary about but people really like the
look especially the hair
i like your hair like this i do like the
hair i like the hair
i love this for you today is the day i'm
going to try and recreate
the style of chase's instagram posts
there's a big step in the journey for me
to become an e-boy i think because this
is a look i don't typically wear
and so for me to put myself on social
media looking this way is gonna be uh
it's gonna be a new experience for me
what do you think of this look jack
you're kind of sick bro you gotta be
more confident you're so like
timid when you're showing people you're
like i don't know this is uh this is
no don't don't question be bold you're
[ __ ] e-boy bro
i posted the picture on instagram the
way chase would have posted it using his
advice
with captions i do a lot of song lyrics
i have a lot of like
deep quotes and stuff like that in my
notes i find a song lyric that resonates
with me and then use it as the caption
when i posted the picture instagram that
was crazy
seeing the response from people on
instagram from friends family followers
it was a very positive response and it
was one that helped me really
feel more comfortable in this look this
is actually only one of several looks
don't have this week so
i want to treat this this will be a
whole week you're doing this all week
god bless oh wow
look how lucky we are for me
since i already was quite nervous about
my look on tuesday i went into wednesday
knowing i had to really embrace the look
bro chasing a few of his photos he's
added eye shadow
i hate this which was a struggle for me
mainly because i don't like things near
my eye
stop moving
wow now this boy i would totally go on a
date with i don't know who's right
around it to
you i don't know how to look at you you
look hot yeah i feel like it suits you
more than you think
i like it i'm sweating stop
yeah i like this one oh merle i'm sorry
girl
you're very clustered i think wednesday
slowly started becoming a real turning
point for me because i was really
starting to really feel the look
you look really brooding do you look
like you might recite a sad poem
stop looking at me
this represents your soft pointness this
is the death
of soft boy aria
hey uh i'm really in the mood for a
milkshake right now
get the [ __ ] out of here i would go
i'm like into this jump it on the ground
throw it
yeah you don't care about it you don't
care goodbye
guys bye thank you please keep that out
there i'm getting laid tonight
oh my god going to thursday i was
already feeling
a lot more confident and that was good
because thursday was definitely my most
aggressive look
what do you think of this look all of
these hit me in a really awful way at
first but then i kind of like it
i like the beanie i feel like the ebook
energy coursing through me as this week
goes on so i'm just gonna embrace this
look
are you gonna wear makeup again with
this no not this one
the thing is i was nervous about this
look but at the same time i was also
feeling a little bit more confident
going into it because of how i was
starting to really enjoy
the e-boy looks i had been trying out
obviously tick-tock is a very big part
of
e-boy culture so for thursday's
challenge i would decide i was going to
try and replicate one of chase's tick
tocks
there was a tick tock of chase
lip-synching to a song and
grabbing at himself uh in a very
suggestive manner
and so i went into the buzzfeed bathroom
grew up myself a bit to the music
and tried matching his movements
[Music]
like really swing those hips okay i
think tick-tock has become like super
popular because
of all that it brings okay you're in
there bro like on your for you page
whatever you like you start to see more
so if you like funny things you're going
to see a lot of funny things like
dancing you see a lot more dancing
it's based around like what you like to
see
[Music]
we've been here for about almost half an
hour but i think
i think we got it i'll post it now
here we are friday the last day of being
an eboy
and i'm am i apparently and the
challenge for me today
on my final day has been to live out
chase's daily routine
it is very bright uh it's 7am woke up i
took a shower
got on this look i will be honest
this is not my favorite look
oh you have like a little pete wentz's
asian cousin
i ate a lot of fruit do you have a
favorite type of fruit raspberries
oh those are tart all right let's go to
work
i'll like wake up a friend then we'll go
talk and like plan out what it is we
want to do other day like content-wise
morning dude what are you doing i'm
gonna go to the gym
no you're not we're gonna make some
content
jack's back he's here to take a photo of
me so we're creating content as
as chase does
i usually spend like an hour just
responding to emails stuff like that
and after that just like i don't know
post a selfie out of my story or
something like that
and like grab your throat or something
oh my god
no and like roll your eyes back to your
head if you can
yeah that's kind of dick bro
that's kind of sick i go live right
after i
i go and i post i'm here with megan hi
do i french fries
no so we're gonna go live hi who else
loves french fries
i don't usually go live on my instagram
but i did enjoy interacting with people
and so i probably will be going live
again in the future so
follow me we eat a lot of talk about
like in the past we could probably add
like four times and i'm trying to eat
healthier
i do like sweets but i also do try to
stay away from junk food and fast food
and so ordering chase's specific order
not the best not the best i felt very
greasy afterwards
but i guess that's the cost of living
the life of an e boy
overall i would describe this week as
being very
very surprising i would never have
thought that a other people
would like the looks that i was wearing
this week and most importantly be
that i would actually like them too
everybody was kind of into it like
not just me this week definitely pushed
me outside of my comfort zone in a way
i'd never have before when it comes to
my looks i think because of the social
media attention
and the irl attention you can definitely
tell he's owning it now
aria is a man of many faces and i guess
i didn't know he had an e-boy face
i like it before we wrap this though i
was looking at chase's instagram
and there was one thing i did notice
that he had
which i don't
oh my god you gotta oh my god aria
actually i kind of like it honestly just
don't care about
what people think be yourself that's how
i've always kept it at and i live by
that
i do me you know you should do you
[Music]
one two three this is our world